J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK.
So we're going to finish up on
nucleophilic substitution,
SN2, where we're spending so
much time looking at how you
prove a mechanism.
And then look at the
elimination, that's second
order, and then the substitution
and elimination
that are first order
kinetically.
We've looked at proving
mechanisms, that is disproving
mechanisms by stereochemistry,
by rate law, by rate constant,
varying all the different
components of the reaction.
And finally there's another way,
which is to look at
structure, which you can do
either with quantum mechanics
or by X-ray.
The problem, remember, is this
really subtle distinction, one
that probably doesn't make much
difference.
But if you're really looking
carefully at mechanism and
want to understand them it's an
interesting question, which
is, is there an energy minimum
at the top?
Is there an intermediate in the
concerted SN2 reaction, or
is it just a transition state?
And of course they blend into
one another as the stability
of the pentavalent intermediate,
if there were
one, gets less and less.
The interesting thing is when
you have the nucleophile, a
leaving group and a carbon in
the middle, trivalent carbon,
is it actually a pentavalent
carbon?
Is there some stability
associated with that?
You could imagine arranging
groups like oxygens, so there
are unshared pairs are on the
left and right, and a planar
carbon cation in the middle and
see whether
there's a bond there.
How are you going to get them?
Remember the non-bonded
distances between atoms, when
they're in contact, is about
twice as big as bonded
distances, right?
So if the thing is only
marginally stable, what's going
to keep it from flying apart?
How will that last long enough
for you to look at it?
Well, you can put other things
in a molecule that hold those
pieces in place, like this set
of three aromatic rings of the
anthracene system.
Now we've got the groups up
there on top where we want and
the question is going to be--
Well first, how do we get them
there?
The thing in the middle started
as an ester, right?
But we want it to be a cation
with a vacant p
orbital in the middle.
So what you do is react it with
a molecule we've talked
about before, Meerwein's
reagent, which is a way of
giving methyl groups.
It's got a great leaving group
on it.
A dimethyl ether is the leaving
group.
We can have a substitution
reaction and put a methyl
group on and now the carbon has
a positive charge.
Although if you want to be
careful about it, not all the
positive charge is on carbon
because the unshared pairs on
the adjacent oxygens, of course,
are mixing with that
vacant orbital.
We've got our trivalent carbon
cation in the middle.
There we see it.
There should be this anion that
was left from the
original Meerwein salt.
And the people who did the X-ray
work we're surprised to
find that it was not BF4 minus,
but B2F7 minus.
It had gotten together with
another BF3.
That's neither here nor there,
but it's what was
there in the crystal.
They have the oxygens next to
the central carbon.
And remember, calculated when
you had a cation with waters
on both sides of a trivalent
carbon, was that at the
symmetrical pentavalent, quote,
"geometry," it was a
transition state.
OK?
If you believed in the theory,
you wouldn't expect there to
be stability here now.
How do you know if there's
stability?
How do you know if there are
bonds there?
Well, you can look in the paper
that's cited down there
on the bottom right, and it
shows a picture and you can
see that indeed there are bonds
there.
Right?
That's supposed to engender a
laugh.
I see Chris smiling.
Why do you smile?
STUDENT: They just drew
the bonds.
PROFESSOR: They just drew the
bonds, right?
How do you know there are bonds
there?
Well there's one interesting
thing.
This structure is symmetrical,
as drawn.
And, you notice these funny
shapes the atoms have. What
they are, are ellipses with an
octant cut out of them to show
the size of the axes.
And one thing you measure in
X-ray is how
much the atoms vibrate.
Those show how much it vibrates
in the three
principal directions for
vibration.
If we look at that C19, the
central carbon there, notice
it's not elongated.
It would be elongated if it
vibrated with great amplitude
back and forth.
It would move a lot in that
direction.
So it could be-- remember in
X-ray, what you see is the
average structure over many
molecules--
it could have been that one of
them is like this another one
is like this, another one was
like this,
another is like this.
And the average would appear to
be in the middle.
But it would have a long
displacement, on the
average, you see.
But that's not what you see
there.
It could be like this bell
clapper or sometimes there,
sometimes there, but on average
in the middle.
But it's not because it's not
stretched out that way.
That still didn't answer the
question, whether they're
bonds there.
It could be in the middle, but
no bonds.
So let's look right edge-on at
the central carbon.
And ask the question, how far
apart are those two oxygens?
If the interaction is repulsive
then they should
move apart.
If it's attractive they should
move together.
Compared to what?
Well, the authors compared it
with the two carbons they were
attached to, which are 5.02
angstroms apart.
And the white is 4.86.
So, they've been drawn together.
The distance is shortened by
0.16 angstoms, as if they're
being sucked in.
That looks like there's a
pentavalent carbon that's
actually attracting those
adjacent oxygens.
This was published in a
distinguished journal, the
Journal of the American Chemical
Society.
And notice that it's not only
that distance but you can see
also that the angles are
distorted.
Instead of those being 120
degree angles out on the left
there, one of them is larger and
one of them
is 7 degrees smaller.
It's bent in, as if it's being
sucked by the central carbon,
so that there's a bond there.
So pentavalence seemed to be a
safe inference, and that was
the subject of this paper.
But, if they did compared to
what, and just had hydrogen in
the middle instead of that
positive carbon, it turned out
they were sucked in even
further.
So instead of being 4.84,
whatever it is, it's 4.75
angstroms. So much for that
proof, that these groups are
being sucked in.
With nothing in the middle, just
the hydrogen,
they're sucked in?
Now, notice that there wasn't
just that
positive carbon there.
There were these other things,
the oxygens, and the methyls.
There was some space to that
which could have
pushed things apart.
Now lacking that push apart,
they come together closer.
From one point of view, that's
reasonable, but why should they
come together?
It's not a pull to the central
carbon.
It seems to be a push.
Where is the push coming from?
Can anybody see?
What pushes those methoxy
groups, the oxygens, toward
the center?
Helen?
STUDENT: Maybe it's the steric
hinderance or the strain of
the two methyls.
PROFESSOR: What are the methyls
being pushed by?
STUDENT: ...
PROFESSOR: It must be some push
to bend those angles in.
Anybody got an idea?
Chris?
STUDENT: Is it with the
hydrogens?
PROFESSOR: Ah, the hydrogens.
Right?
They're eclipsed.
And there's repulsion there that
causes them to bend in.
Now, you can put instead of a
positive carbon, you can put
oxygen in the middle with this
extra group on it.
And that, you see, does push
them further apart.
But still they're bent in a
little bit as
compared to the carbon.
But the central oxygen is only
slightly repulsive, compared
to the carbon.
So the carbon's not pulling
things in at all.
It's pushing them out trying to
fight against that hydrogen
pushing into the methyl out on
the side.
If you have BF3 in the middle,
which clearly has the vacant
orbital on boron, has very small
other things on the
boron, so they're not pushing
apart.
And those other things are
fluorine, so not only are they
small, but they're withdrawing
electrons and making that B
orbital especially low in
energy.
Then you can see them genuinely
being sucked in,
further than in any of the other
cases, as compared there
to the positive carbon in the
middle.
Now, if you try to make the
things on the outside more
willing to give up their
electrons, that is higher
HOMOs to make stronger bonds,
and make it O
minus rather than CH3O.
So we have the minus charge
raising those HOMOs.
Then indeed, it forms a bond,
but not two bonds.
It's unsymmetrical.
One of them is a reasonable
bond.
The other one is just a
non-bonded interaction.
In fact it turns out that this
is a salt.
It's an anion.
So there's a positive cation
nearby, a potassium, which
makes it a little bit
unsymmetrical.
So it's better to have the minus
charge on the right near
the potassium cation than on the
left.
That also helps distort it.
Now remember that as compared to
the anion that was
calculated, which again, was
said to be by calculation a
transition state.
Here are a whole bunch of things
they studied, and I
don't want to spend the time
going through
this in great detail.
But compared to what?
Compared to just having a
hydrogen in the middle-- to see
what these distances are.
Then in the case where C+ was in
the middle--
they made the C+ that way-- but
it's not such a great C+
because of the vacant orbital on
the carbon being mixed with
the unshared pairs on the
adjacent oxygens.
But if you have--
if the central atom is bonded to
oxygen or sulfur, which has
these extra electrons, that
seems to use
up the vacant orbital.
So it's not so good at bonding
and therefore
sucking things in.
If you have fluorine on boron
then, as we said, the electron
withdrawal lowers the energy and
indeed it does seem to
suck it in to give a
pentavalent atom in the middle.
But if you have higher HOMOs on
the neighbor of the boron,
giving their electrons to the
boron, then that's a better
source of electrons for the
boron than the
neighboring atoms are.
And you can see in these cases.
If you look at this whole bunch
of things plotted in
this particular way, you can
see, for example, there's
boron with two chlorines in the
middle and methoxides on
both sides.
The bar then shows the two
different bond distances.
So it's unsymmetrical.
One is short, one is long.
It's not a pentavalent carbon.
There's some that are like that
on the right, very
different and unsymmetrical.
Then there's some on the left
that are about equal bond
distances, right and left or
symmetrical.
There's our reference with
hydrogen in the middle.
And it's pressed in to give
somewhat short distances by
the hydrogen pushing on the
methyl as
we spoke about before.
If you have boron in the middle
it's not
sucked in very much.
Unless you have that case with
fluorine on the boron, and then
it attracts enough that you
could make a pentavalent atom
in the middle.
But most of the borons are
tetracoordinate, that is
unsymmetrical not a single
minimum but a double minimum.
If you look at the two cases of
carbon, the one with
oxygens on each side there on
the left, is
symmetrical but not short.
And the one on the right is
short, one of them is short,
but the other is long.
It's not symmetrical.
There's no sign from this
exercise for a pentavalent
intermediate of the SN2 sort
being stable.
It seems genuinely to be just a
maximum on the way across.
So it's a transition state as
calculated by quantum
mechanics, so that should give
us a little more confidence,
perhaps, in the reliability of
quantum mechanics, which of
course, can't take into account
all the neighbors
around the molecule.
That's as far as we're going to
go looking at the mechanism
of the SN2.
Now we're going to look at
alternative paths of reaction,
the elimination reaction, which
we already mentioned
last semester and also first
order nucleophilic
substitution and elimination.
First E2, or beta-elimination.
Now, this is from last semester.
You remember, you can attack
here with a high HOMO,
antibonding here, antibonding
here.
You break off flouride.
You break off hydrogen, and form
the carbon-carbon bond,
as shown by the curved arrows
here.
We said last semester that
that's the
E2 elimination mechanism.
What influences the rate?
The rate is influenced by the
base.
That's what makes it second
order.
It depends not only on the
concentration of this
substrate but also on the
concentration of hydroxide.
The two must be getting together
in the rate-limiting
step, or before the
rate-limiting step in a
preliminary equilibrium that
gets drawn off.
That's the same thinking as we
had on the SN2, that both
things are involved in the
rate-limiting, or before, the
rate-limiting step.
It depends on the nature of the
leaving group.
A better leaving group reacts
faster.
So that means that the fluoride
is leaving in the
rate-limiting step, or before
the rate-limiting step in a
pre-equilibrium.
There's a hydrogen isotope
effect, called a kinetic
isotope effect.
If you change hydrogen for
deuterium, you change the rate,
and this has special
implication,
as you can see here.
These others only meant it was
at the transition state, or
before the transition state,
that something was happening.
But if this makes a difference
it shows that bond is being
broken during the transition
state.
We know the leaving group is
leaving,
we know the base is
coming in, those
two things either
before or at the
transition state, and now we
know the hydrogen is leaving
at the transition state, and
let's see how that works.
We saw in "Erwin Meets
Goldilocks that you have a
vibrational potential surface.
And you'd have also a
vibrational potential surface
for the hydrogen that's being
transferred after it's
transferred.
It's stuck first place to the
carbon, in the second place to
the oxygen.
But halfway across, when the
bond is being broken, it's
between the two so it's not
being bound to either.
It's very low--
It's easy to move back and forth
when
it's halfway between.
What implication does this have
for the kinetic energy of
that hydrogen?
Remember, there's a lowest
possible kinetic energy, the
one that gives no nodes in the
wave. It'll be here in that
case, here in the oxygen case,
but when it's very easy to
move you can stretch the wave
way out, very little
curvature, very little kinetic
energy.
So you can have much lower
minimum kinetic energy when
the hydrogen bond is being
broken than when it's either
attached to the carbon or
attached to the oxygen.
What's the implication of that?
When you do the reaction you
have to get to the transition
state so you have to put in that
much energy.
What's the implication if we
change
from hydrogen to deuterium?
You remember what happens when
you change the mass in "Erwin
Meets Goldilocks to the lowest
energy?
If you make them into
deuteriums, then you have a
wave that looks like this, but
the bigger mass means it has
lower energy.
So, we have lower energy here,
lower energy here, and lower
energy here, but it can't be
lower than the minimum.
There's hardly any change in the
energy here, when you go
from hydrogen to deuterium, but
there's a substantial change
here and a substantial change
here.
If you look at the energy that's
required for the
reaction, more energy is
required for the deuterium,
because it started lower.
If you were talking about an
equilibrium between here and
here, then that difference would
cancel out.
It's only in that transition
stage, which has the very low
potential, that means that
there's something special
about the deuterium, or perhaps
you should say
something NOT special about the
deuterium.
When it's bonded, it's unusually
low in energy, but
when it's not tightly bonded,
then it has the
same energy as hydrogen.
Because you have more of a
barrier for deuterium, the
reaction should be slower.
Hydrogen is faster than
deuterium if that is the
rate-limiting step.
If that's not the rate-limiting
step, if it
happens before this or after
this, then you don't have the
difference between hydrogen and
deuterium.
It's only when the hydrogen is
being broken away during the
transition state, during the
rate-determining step, that
you can see it.
You get that difference in
rates, that so-called kinetic
isotope effect, only if bond is
being weakened in the
rate-determining transition
state.
There's another interesting
implication as there was in
SN2, which is stereochemistry.
So we have a hydrogen and a
leaving group that are going
to come off.
And if we look at that from the
end with the Newman
projection, we see them anti to
one another.
We can imagine pulling the two
off and forming a bond by
what's left.
They could've been syn to one
another in an eclipsed
conformation.
Which should be better?
Should we pull them off anti to
one another
or syn to one another?
Well of course, the top
conformation
would involve eclipsing.
So that would be higher in
energy than the anti.
And furthermore it turns out,
although we don't have time to
talk about it right now, that
anti orbitals overlap with one
another better than syn
orbitals.
To me, that seems
counterintuitive.
You'd think when they're like
this, they'd overlap better
than when they're like that.
But in fact they overlap better
when they're anti.
By both accounts, one would
expect the anti to be the
preferred mode for elimination.
But is it true?
How could you test it
experimentally?
How could you tell whether they
had been pulled off, or
were being pulled off, from the
same side or
from opposite sides?
Well, if you look at the title
of the slide you use
stereochemistry.
Notice then, that if we put R
groups on here, then when we
lose H and L here these two R's
will be on the same side.
But if it's rotated into this
form, then they'll be on
opposite sides of the new double
bond that's being made
across the middle.
We can start, for syn
elimination of this particular
compound, where notice this
configuration is S and that
one also is S. It's rotated into
a conformation where the
leaving groups are syn to one
another.
Of course it could rotate, and
they could
be anti to one another.
And the question is, which one
really happens?
We can look at the product and
find that the two methyls are
on the same side of the double
bond as they are
here, both in back.
Where as here, one's in front,
the other's in back.
This suggests then that the fact
that one gets the E
isomer of the alkene that it was
the anti form that gave
rise to it.
Stereochemistry showed that it's
anti
elimination in this case.
Of course there could have been
another reason for anti
elimination.
It could've been that this
product is more stable than
the one where the phenyl group
is near the methyl.
How can we discriminate whether
it's just that it's
the preferred conformation and
anti is good for the reason
shown here, or whether the only
reason you get that one
is because it's more stable?
Can anybody see how you can test
that?
You could use a different
stereochemistry on the
starting material and see if it
still gives that one.
So maybe E is just more stable
than the Z isomer.
Here we can change the
configuration on the right to
make it R. The methyl is now in
back and the hydrogen in
front here.
So now the syn is the one
that should give
the E isomer,
and the anti
should give the Z. In fact, you
see it is Z. So no matter
which way--
it can't be just because this
one is more stable, because if
you change it you get that one.
It has to be that it favors the
anti conformation for the
elimination.
There's anti stereochemistry but
nature is not dogmatic
about this.
If you can't do the anti, then
the syn is still OK.
And here's an example of that
taken from the Jones textbook.
Notice that in this case, the
treatment with base to
eliminate hydrogen or deuterium
from this side and
tosylate from that side, removes
the deuterium, leaving
two hydrogens.
It gives that a 98% yield even
though those two are required
to be syn to one another
because, again, this bicyclic
framework, the same one used by
Bartlett and Knox, that idea
of holding things in place that
way, doesn't allow
conformational change around
here.
So these have to be syn to one
another.
It loses DOTs not HOTs despite
the kinetic isotope effect.
Remember hydrogen is eliminated
in preference to
deuterium, other things being
equal.
Other things aren't equal as you
can look here.
If you do a sort of semi-Newman
projection along
this bond you can see the D and
OTs, their bonds are in
the same plane.
So in this rigid, eclipsed case
the overlap of sigma-star
here, which is losing its
electrons
that is, as the OTs minus leaves
this vacant orbital is able to
overlap well and stabilize the
sigma orbitals in this bond, so
it takes away those
electrons and D+ leaves.
So, the eclipsed D is better
than H which would be better
if it could be anti.
But this framework doesn't allow
it to be anti.
There's not good overlap between
the H and the OTs.
It's anticlinal.
Notice in this case you don't
have to pay a penalty for
having the starting
material for the
syn elimination eclipsed.
It's required to be eclipsed by
the nature of the linkage
among the carbons.
That's a question of
stereochemistry, whether you
get E or Z isomer.
There's also a question of
what's called regiochemistry.
Where does the double bond
appear?
If the leaving group is here on
the second carbon, and you
treat it with base to remove H
and L, then you can get the
double bond either in this
position, or in this position.
And that can be both cis and
trans.
I draw only the trans isomer.
You could remove a blue hydrogen
or a red hydrogen.
And this is the kind of thing,
where before people knew
anything about mechanism, people
tried to figure out how
you can get a certain product
and different pathways.
This was just lore:
this would do this:
this would do this.
There were two kinds of rules.
One was the rule due the
Hofmann.
The other was the rule due to
Saytzeff.
So there was the Saytzeff rule,
which said you should take off
the blue hydrogen.
And there was the Hofmann rule
that you should take off the
red hydrogen.
Some cases did one, and some
cases did the other.
And it was your business if you
were a synthetic chemist
to know which ones did which, so
you would know what kind of
leaving group to choose or what
kind of base to choose to
get the particular products you
were desirous of.
If you have the leaving group of
the halogens, iodine,
bromine, chlorine, you see
they're Saytzeff.
The dominant isomer you get is
in the second position not the
terminal position.
But notice as we go iodine,
bromine, chlorine it gets less
and less Saytzeff.
In fact if you go to fluoride it
turns around and it becomes
Hofmann in its orientation.
The same is true for the leaving
group being
trimethylamine.
The trimethyl ammonium starting
material loses this
trimethylamine and this proton,
so it's 98% of Hofmann
orientation.
This big group seems to be
Hofmann.
Iodide seems to be Saytzeff.
Let's look a little bit about
the energetics that are
involved here.
This is a ratio of about 4:1.
This is about 1:50.
The whole range, which is very
important, what you're
going to be getting, is only a
factor of 200
between 4:1 and 1:50.
So 400 means a factor of 10^2.3,
which means that it's
about three kilocalories change
in energy that makes it
from going 4:1 one way, to 50:1
the other way.
A change of just three
kilocalories.
Remember that a hydrogen bond--
not a particularly strong
hydrogen bond--is worth three
kilocalories.
So you can see that subtle
things are going
to enter into this.
It's not surprising that there
are not hard and fast rules,
that sometimes it's Saytzeff and
sometimes it's Hofmann.
This is a very subtle thing.
It's important for synthesis,
but it's not a big factor that
you could be confident, that you
could put your finger on
it and say that's the reason it
went that way.
You can have E2 versus SN2.
You could have the high HOMO
come in, either attack a
carbon or take a hydrogen.
How well do we understand what
does that?
Suppose we take t-butyl.
To do an SN2 reaction you'd have
to attack there, but
we've seen this picture before
and you know
that's sterically hindered.
You can't get in there.
Steric hindrance tends to
disfavor SN2 processes.
But it's much easier to get to
the neighboring hydrogen and
pull it off.
It's on the surface of the
molecule.
Steric hindrance favors E2 over
SN2.
It does it by disfavoring SN2.
If you have a very hindered
center, you tend to get
elimination, not substitution.
That makes perfect sense.
Furthermore, remember when we
looked at nucleophilicity, how
good things are at attacking
carbon, we tried to see
whether it would be the same as
attacking hydrogen.
There wasn't such good
parallelism. Some things were
more dramatic in their pKa in
attacking hydrogen than they
were in attacking carbon.
That obviously means that if you
take something that's a
fairly weak nucleophile,
compared to how basic it is,
the pKa, if you look at those
which are grossly out of whack,
then they could be ones that
would prefer
attacking the hydrogen.
For example, hydroxide is of
that case.
It's a strong base but not as
good a nucleophile as you
would expect for such a strong
base.
So hydroxide, or alkoxide, tends
to do elimination rather
than substitution.
But always these are a balancing
act and it could depend on
other factors as well.
I've given the title of these
next things Synthesis Games
because synthesis is for many
people the real goal of
organic chemistry is how to make
new molecules, or make
old molecules in better ways.
One of the best ways is to
follow lore.
But it's also guided by
understanding.
There has been lots of progress
made in the last
fifty years because of people
having studied mechanism.
If something isn't going right
you have some idea what you
might change in order to make
it, not just looking up in the
literature to see what people
did before, although that
remains a very important
procedure.
We saw all these different
nucleophilic substitution
reactions, and the question then
if you're trying to apply
somebody else's work to yours,
is how general they are.
For example, the Williamson
ether synthesis,
how general is it?
For example here's the compound,
MTBE.
Have you ever heard of that?
I bet you've seen the word.
Or the acronym.
It's methyl t-butyl ether.
Have you ever seen MTBE?
Where did you see it?
STUDENTS: Lab.
PROFESSOR: On the gasoline pump.
This is an additive to gasoline.
So it's made in enormous
quantities.
Here, you want to make this
ether.
Here's a way to do it.
You can start with methanol,
treat it with sodium hydride.
There is a high HOMO which can
attack the proton and take it
away as H2, leaving the sodium
salt of methoxide.
We have a nucleophile.
Now if we want to make this bond
here, the one between the
oxygen and the tertiary carbon,
then we would react it
with t-butyl bromide.
Are you going to get rich in the
petroleum industry, making
MTBE that way?
Are there any problems?
What have we just been talking
about?
The competition between
substitution and elimination.
And what are the factors that
favor E2 over SN2?
Amy?
STUDENT: Steric hindrance.
PROFESSOR: Steric hindrance.
Right?
Crowded here.
It's hard for this oxygen to get
at the carbon.
And what else?
If you have an anion, a
nucleophile, that's even
better as a base, taking
hydrogen.
Here we have the worst of all
possible worlds.
We have something that wants to
take hydrogen, and something
that doesn't want to be attacked
at the carbon.
So you get elimination.
It's too hindered for SN2, and
the strong base favors E2.
All you get is the double bond
compound.
You don't get methyl t-butyl
ether.
Does the Williamson synthesis
then not work?
Do you just throw up your hands,
if
you're a synthetic chemist?
We said we wanted to make MTBE.
We wanted to make that
oxygen-carbon bond.
Can you see any alternative?
To make this ether?
You can make that oxygen-carbon
bond.
There's more than one way to
skin this kind of cat.
That one won't work.
But if we do it the other way
around and make this anion,
which again would prefer to
eliminate rather than
substitute.
But you attack methyl bromide
which can't eliminate because
it doesn't have a hydrogen on
the other carbon because it
doesn't have another carbon.
Now you've got the MTBE in high
yield although nobody
makes it that way.
The stuff that's made for
petroleum is made a different
way, and we'll talk about that a
little later on.
Anyhow, this illustrates that
often there are different ways
of choosing putting the reagents
together.
One will work and one won't work
for reasons that you can
understand mechanistically.
Here's another interesting
synthetic intermediate which
is, if you start with a compound
that has OH and
chlorine on adjacent atoms and
notice it has one in the front
and one in the back.
You treat this with base.
It gives this funny ether, an
ether that's a
three-membered ring.
It does so in pretty good yield.
How does it do it?
Well, hydroxide takes off this
proton and can you see what
happens next?
It's a reaction that's familiar
to you.
We want to make this bond.
How do we make that second bond,
the new bond, in the
three-membered ring?
It's an SN2 reaction.
This HOMO attacks sigma-star
backside, so it's an
intramolecular SN2 reaction.
And chloride leaves to generate
this
three-membered ring.
The three-membered ether is
called sometimes epoxide,
sometimes oxirane.
Some people call it one, some
call it the other.
In fact, epoxides are very
useful synthetic intermediates,
because, although R-O minus is a
crummy leaving group, in
this case it's helped by losing
the ring strain.
So it's spring-loaded to open
up.
You can attack here with some
nucleophile, break the bond,
the O minus comes away, and this
gives a way of adding
C-C-O to a nucleophile.
You bring some nucleophile in,
and it adds to the nucleophile
two carbons and then an oxygen.
Synthetic chemists often think,
what is it?
If I want to get this product,
that's something plus C-C-O.
How could I do that?
Ethylene oxide.
That epoxide can do it.
In fact we're going to talk more
about that as a synthetic
intermediate later.
For example, that's the stuff
from which you make crown
ethers because it has, remember,
C-C-O, C-C-O, C-C-O,
but we'll talk about that in a
few lectures further on.
For synthetic purposes a
particularly useful set of
nucleophiles is cyanide,
acetylide, the thing you get
by losing a proton from
acetylene, and this other type
of anion, which has an
alpha-anion.
It's lost a proton adjacent to
carbonyls.
We talked about that one before.
The reason these are interesting
is because they
are nucleophiles that form
carbon-carbon bonds.
Most of the things we've talked
about replace one
functional group by another.
A leaving group goes away.
The new one comes in.
The new one is typically
something
like oxygen or nitrogen.
But these anions have carbon
coming in and that means you
make a new carbon skeleton.
That's something that's very
important in putting together
organic molecules.
Notice that these two both have
a pKa of 9.
You put the starting material--
that is, the protonated forms
have a pKa of 9--
put them in with base and you
get the anion
and it does its trick.
Acetylide
is pKa of 25.
You can't use that in water.
It would immediately take the
proton away from water.
So it's a base, and it actually
tends to do elimination
sometimes rather than
substitution.
So you need a stronger base if
you want to pull off a proton
and do that.
You can do it with sodium amide
notice that this is the
anion coming from NH3 as the
acid.
And NH3 then is the product
after it's
pulled off this proton.
And it is a much, much stronger
base, a much weaker
acid by nine powers of 10 than
the acetylide is.
You could make it that way.
These could be important in
synthesis.
We'll see later on in the course
how very important
nucleophiles that are carbon are
in
putting molecules together.
Now if we look at the rate of
the reaction of sodium
hydroxide with an alkyl bromide,
for different R groups.
We're going to look at a log
scale so we can cover five
powers of 10 in the rate.
And it's how much of R-Br gets
converted to HO-R per minute.
We're going to do it in
ethanol/water, 4:1 at 55
degrees.
We see 1% about 10^-2, of methyl
bromide is converted to
this ether--
or pardon me, to the alcohol--
per minute, 1% per minute.
If we make it ethyl bromide,
it's only a tenth of a percent
per minute.
What would you expect for
isopropyl?
Looks good.
What do you expect for t-butyl?
So there's something funny.
Something has changed when we
went from methyl, ethyl,
isopropyl, and t-butyl.
This was done with 0.01 molar
sodium hydroxide
getting these rates.
It turns out that the rate of
these depends on how much
hydroxide there is.
That doesn't surprise you, it's
SN2.
Depends on how much of the
nucleophile there is.
In fact, if you looked at the
second-order rate constant,
which takes into account the
concentration of base, then
you see these fall on a nice
curve and it's slowed down by
crowding, the steric hindrance
that we talked about before.
But you'd expect t-butyl to be
down here someplace.
In fact, it's up there.
That's because that one is not
dependent on hydroxide.
It's not SN2.
The rate doesn't depend both on
the
halide and the hydroxide.
It depends only on the halide.
At the rate-determining step,
the base hasn't gotten
involved yet.
Notice that it's accelerated by
crowding.
When you get to the most crowded
one, that mechanism
goes really fast. It can happen
because the cation is
more stable when it's more
substituted.
It's also accelerated by a polar
solvent.
If you try a solvent that's not
polar, it's harder to make
ions in it.
But the ethanol and water is a
reasonably polar solvent.
"This is the SN1 reaction, as
opposed to SN2.
This categorization was
formulated, SN1, SN2, in
England, in London, in the 1930s
by Hughes and Ingold.
That rate actually wasn't
measured at that temperature.
They measured at a lower
temperature and figured out
what it would be at this
temperature.
This is how much is converted to
HO-R but some of the
starting material is not
converted to HO-R. Some of it
undergoes elimination.
At this stage 19%, about
one-fifth of the product, is
in fact the elimination product,
E2.
The base attacks the adjacent
hydrogen rather than waiting
for it to ionize.
And we know it's E2 because the
amount you get depends on
how much hydroxide you put in
there.
The rate of forming the alcohol,
the rate of the
substitution, doesn't depend on
the hydroxide.
But the rate of forming the
alkene does
depend on the hydroxide.
You change the ratio of the
products by changing the
hydroxide concentration.
Now you can have SN1 and E1 as
well.
In that case we just talked
about, if you put more
hydroxide in, the starting
material goes away more
rapidly because the elimination
is
dependent on hydroxide.
But in the case here where it's
cyanide, that's the high
HOMO, that's doing the
attacking, you find that you
get not only the cyanide
substitution but you also get
substitution by water.
The product ratio depends on how
much cyanide you put in.
That doesn't surprise you.
You put in more cyanide, the
formation of
this product is faster.
But the rate doesn't change.
The rate of destroying the
starting material doesn't
change when you do this.
Can anybody see how that could
be?
How could you change the
products but
not change the rate?
Matt?
STUDENT: Because even though you
have a different ratio, it
could be doing a different
mechanism, possibly.
PROFESSOR: Let's try it here.
We have this starting material
and these two products.
We're going to draw a reaction
coordinate diagram to get from
the starting material to the
products.
Here we formed, as in SN1, an
intermediate cation.
And then it goes on, if there's
cyanide around, to
give that product or with water
to give that product.
What determines the rate of the
process?
What's the rate-determining
step?
The red one, right?
That happens before you decide
which product you get.
If you have more cyanide in
there, more of it
will go this way.
You can change the products
without changing the rate, if
you have this cation
intermediate.
So if the product is determined
after the rate, by
competition for the short lived
cation, that's evidence
that you have a cation
intermediate in this
substitution.
Here's silver nitrate helping to
pull off the
leaving group, iodide.
Notice what's funny in this
case.
Whoops, what's funny is I've
talked my head off here.
There are a few more slides that
I think it would be
helpful to have to make the exam
coherent.
Since the exam's going to be on
Friday, why don't we put a
few more of them onto the next
and I apologize.
I'll let you go now.
We'll do a few more slides next
time for the exam.
And there will be a review
session on Wednesday.